KAYAK. SEARCH ONE AND DONE.
STEVE: WELL, A SMALL TOWN FIRE
DEPARTMENT IN NEW MEXICO RIGHT
NEXT TO EL PASO, TEXAS SEEING A
SPIKE IN RESCUE CALLS TO HELP
ABANDONED OR INJURED MIGRANTS
CROSSING THE BORDER.
SUN LAND PARK, NEW MEXICO IS A
SUBURB OUTSIDE OF EL PASO AS YOU
SEE RIGHT THERE.
AS EL PASO BORDER ENCOUNTERS
JUMP MORE THAN 200 PERCENT FROM
LAST YEAR, OUR NEXT GUEST, THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT CHIEF, FEARS
THAT THINGS COULD ONLY GET
WORSE.
SUNLAND PARK FIRE DEPARTMENT
CHIEF DANIELLE MADRONO JOINS US
RIGHT NOW GOOD MORNING, SIR.
>> GOOD MORNING.
STEVE: GENERALLY IN THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT YOU ARE WOULD BE
SITTING, YOUR MEN AND WOMEN WHO
WORK FOR YOU, WOULD BE SITTING
IN THE FIRE DEPARTMENT WAITING
FOR AN EMERGENCY CALL TO GO HELP
A RESIDENT OF YOUR COMMUNITY.
NOW YOU ARE GETTING CALLS FROM
THE PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY WHO ARE IN TROUBLE.
TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT.
>> WELL, THERE IS A BORDER FENCE
IT, RUNS ANYWHERE FROM 12,
14 FEET TALL TO 30 FEET TALL ON
THE INTERNATIONAL BORDER.
SUNLAND PARK IS ON THAT BORDER
AND PART OF MY RESPONSE
DISTRICT.
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN SEEING A LOT
OF IS MIGRANTS WHO FALL OFF THE
TOP OF THAT WALL.
AND THEY SUSTAIN PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT INJURIES THAT WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS.
STEVE: SURE.
LET’S SAY THEY FALL ON THE
AMERICAN SIDE OF THE WALL
WHETHER A DO YOU DO WITH THEM,
TECHNICALLY THEY CROSSED INTO
THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY I WOULD
IMAGINE YOU SHOULD REPORT THEM
TO THE AUTHORITIES BUT THEN YOU
ARE KIND OF ONE OF THE
AUTHORITIES.
>> WELL, WE ARE A MEDICAL
AUTHORITY.
MOST OF THE CALLS COMING COME IN
FROM BORDER PATROL THEMSELVES.
THEY WILL EITHER WITNESS THE
FALL OR SEE THEM ON CAMERA AND
MAWX THE APPROACH FIRST.
MOST OF THE CALLS ARE BORDER
PATROL ON THE SCENE PRIOR TO US
GETTING THERE.
STEVE: AS I LOOK TETTER RAIN
OVER THERE, IT’S RUGGED.
DO YOU HAVE THE KIND OF VEHICLES
YOU NEED TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM?
>> FIRE TRUCKS CANNOT MAKE IT
ANYWHERE NEAR THESE AREAS.
WE HAVE THIS TO RETROFIT AT
LEAST ONE OF OUR VEHICLES.
SO FAR WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
FITTING MILITARY HUMVEE WE USED
TO USE AS A BRUSH TRUCK TO GET
INTO SOME OF THE EVEN MORE
RUGGED AREAS.
WE HAVE THOUGH ADDRESS THIS BY
DOING SO, SURE.
STEVE: WELL, THAT MEANS YOU NEED
MORE MONEY TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE.
IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TAKING
ON MORE CASH FOR YOU BECAUSE YOU
ARE TAKING ON MORE
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> WE HAVEN’T SEEN ANY MONEY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AT
ALL.
THIS IS SOMETHING I HAD TO
ADDRESS IMMEDIATELY SO I HAD TO
USE MY OWN BUDGET.
SO, GETTING MONEY FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS A LITTLE
BIT TIME CONSUMING.
STEVE: SURE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THOUGH, CHIEF,
YOU ARE THE FIRE DEPARTMENT, AND
YOU ARE THERE TO HELP PEOPLE IN
YOUR COMMUNITY WHEN FIRE BREAKS
OUT OR THERE IS A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY.
BUT NOW YOU ARE BEING ASKED TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITY
OF HELPING PEOPLE WHO ARE
BREAKING INTO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY, THAT’S NOT EXACTLY
WHAT YOU SIGNED UP FOR
ORIGINALLY.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE LOOK AT
EVERY PATIENT THE SAME WAY.
WE DON’T ASK FOR IMMIGRATION
PAPERS.
WE TREAT EVERY PATIENT AS A
MEDICAL PATIENT.
SO, IT WE DON’T KNOW IF THEY’RE
IN HERE ILLEGALLY OR NOT.
IT’S OUR ASSUMPTION.
WE TREAT THEM AS SUCH.
STEVE: THE NUMBER OF CALLS YOU
ARE CALLED ON HAS GONE UP
SUBSTANTIALLY, HASN’T IT?
>> WE HAVE -- WE ESTIMATE IT’S
GONE UP ABOUT 6% TO 7%.
ESPECIALLY IN THE SOUTHERN PART
OF OUR RESPONSE DISTRICT.
IT CLEAN-UP IS NOT A HUGE NUMBER
BUT SPEAKING WITH BORDER PATROL,
WE ANTICIPATE THOSE NUMBERS
SHOULD GO UNJUST BY THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY ARE GIVING
US?
THAT THEY MAY SEE MORE MIGRANTS
COMING OVER.
STEVE: YOU HAVE GOT YOUR HANDS
FULL.